تناولنا من يومين معلومات عن
نيه متى انها تسرح عدد من موظفيها بسبب
تراجع سعر اسهمها بنسبه 70 في ال 100
وارتفاع معدل الانفاق الجديد اليوم واللي
ممكن نسميه العنوان العريض على خطه تويتر
متى بتسرح موظفيها في اليوم متى سرحت
فعليا اكثر من 11.000 موظف من سبعه
وثمانون الف موظف يعني 13% وهذه العمليه
هي الاكبر والاوسع من وقت تاسيس متى من 18
سنه الرئيس التنفيذي لمتن مارك ذكر برج
الرساله للموظفين وقال فيها انه هذه
التغييرات من اصعب التغييرات في تاريخ
الشركه وشرح الاسباب اللي خلت الشركه انها
توصل الى هذا القرار واللي من بينها
النتائج العكسيه اللي ما توقعها بسبب
انكماش او انكماش اقتصاد الكلي من بعد جاء
احد كورونا والخطوات السريعه للتخدها هذا
غير المنافسه من بعض التطبيقات وخساره
الاعلانات في نظام اي او اس اللي تسببت في
انخفاض عائدات متى وقال انه هو بيتحمل
مسؤوليه ذلك وقال مايك في رساله انه
الموظفين المشرحين راح يوصل لهم بريد
الكتروني بفقدان عملهم ابتداء من صباح
اليوم وراح يحصلوا على راتب اربع شهور
واجر اسبوعين اضافيين عن كل سنه من الخدمه
كان نوع من التعويض عن فقدانهم وتحدث عن
انهم اكثر الاقسام اللي راح تتضرري هي
التسويق والشراكه والموارد البشريه وحقيقه
في معلومات كانت متداوله لانه في خيمه امل
كبيره عند مارك بسبب مشروع متى بس اللي
يكلف الشركه السته 30 مليار دولار ولكنه
ما جاب الايرادات المطلوبه وكان اجل ب
300,000 مستخدم عن الهدف المتوقع في نهايه
السنه والسبب هي انه اغلب التقارير بتقول
انه المستخدمين بعد دخولهم للواقع
الافتراضي بيعانوا من مشاكل صحيه وغ وحتى
صداع مستمر وارتبطت هذه الخساره بخساره
وحده اعمال يصير لابس اللي بتشرف على
انشطه الواقع الافتراضي والواقع المعزز
بتسعه فاصله اربعه مليار دولار وكانت اسهم
متى بتراجعت كمان بنسبه 26% اليوم وكل هذه
التطورات
جعلت من متى حسب التقرير سي ام بي سي
الشركه
الاسواد اداء هذا العام
عبر الزوم ينضم الى الرياض المحرر التقني
في اندبندنت عربيه عبد الله السبع اهلا
فيك معانا عبد الله يعني يعني الناس كانت
مصدومه من الاقالات الجلسه بتصير في تويتر
جا يعني دخل فيسبوك ومارك ذكر برج وقال لك
11,000 ايش اللي بيحصل هذا
شهر العسل في سن الحاليه
شركات كبيره موجوده حاليا في السوق بدات
توقف عمليه التوظيف بشكل كامل ابل
مايكروسوفت
التوظيف بشكل كامل الا في بعض الاقسام
البسيطه طبعا المشاكل اللي مرت فيها خلال
سنوات الماضيه مشاكل كرونه وبعدها انخفاض
والتضخم ثلاث سنوات الماضيه ادت ان الشهر
العسل
كبير جدا في الارباح خمس سنوات الماضيه كل
الشركات التقنيه خلال السنوات الماضيه او
بدايه
كبيره كانت تواجه سعود جدا عالي لكن خلال
فتره الماضيه بدات تواجه مشاكل جدا كبيره
لانها ما قعدت تنمو
موظفينها فيسبوك شبكه اجتماعيه عندها اكثر
من 85,000 موظف حول العالم فلذلك اكيد
تعاني المشاكل بسبب الخصوصيه الجديده في
اغلب الشركات قله العوائد الاعلانيه
ومشاكل جدا وكمان يعني جاك دورسي
اعلن انه حيسرح كثير من الموظفين جاكتروس
اللي هو واحد من مؤسسين تويتر اعتذر وقال
انه هذه غلطه لانه هو كبر الشركه اكثر مما
ينبغي فيبدا انه هذه كمان برده مشكله عامه
شعره في وقت العسل زي ما ذكرت انه يقدر
ويكبروا الان بيدفعوا الثمن طيب اذا قارن
كل هذا الشركات التيك توك هل تيك توك
بواجه نفس هذه المشاكل
لا تك تك خلال السنوات الماضيه قاعدين
ينمو جدا كبير ومضطر لكن لازم نعرف شيء
مو لان يعني قاعد يسوي شيء خارق جديده
اي من الصح حاليا تقدم اي خدمه جديده ممكن
ما تلاقي رواج مستخدمين لازم كمان نعرف
شيء شركه ابل شركه مايكروسوفت خلال سنوات
الماضيه ما قدمت شيء جدا كبير او ثوري صح
ابو الخلان خلال 10 سنوات قدم سماعه ابل
قدمت ساعه ابل لكن بعدها ما بدنا نشوف
منها نظام
سيارات لكنه ما بدها تطبق بشكل جدا كبير
بدات تتوسع في
خدمات الدفع من خلال ابل لكنه حتى الان ما
في شيء توني قاعد يكون فيسبوك راهنت على
الواقع الافتراضي وفشلت فيه لانه كل
الشركات حاليا تدور على البيض اللي قاعد
والدجاجه اللي تبيض لهم همم ذهب همم كل
الشركات قاعد تدور على الفرصه الذهبيه
اللي تطلعهم من دائره في الركود الى دائره
النمو بشكل جيد جدا كثير همم فيسبوك كانت
متامله يعني الواقع الافتراضي هو يكون هو
المجال اللي هو ينجحوا فيه لكن للاسف خلال
سنوات الماضيه قاعدين يبقى كل فتره انه
المسار اللي هم اتخذوهم مسار خاطئ وممكن
انه لما يكون هو هو النجاح
تحديدا عن موضوع اللي هو المتوفي والواقع
الافتراضي وكذا لانه وقت لما طلع يعني
الكل اتكلم انه خلاص احنا هنترك عالمنا ده
وهنروح في الع لما الثانيه هذه والناس
الشركات بدات تشتري هناك محلات واراضي
ومباني وما الى ذلك طيب الان كانه يعني
هذا اسوا وافشل مشروع في التاريخ
الواقع الافتراضي قد يكون مستمر عند الناس
والناس تقدر تستفيد منه لكن مو بنفس
الطريقه اللي احنا عارفينها الان خليني
ارجع لك الى بدايه الالفيه الماضيه كيف
كانت اشكال الكمبيوتر كيف كانت اشكال
التلفزيون ما هي كانت هذه الطريقه اللي
ممكن تنجح فيها كان في جوالك لمس موجوده
لكنها كانت تعتمد على نظام ويندوز كانت
تعتمد على الانظمه مختلفه كانت تعتمد على
القلم لمن جيت ابل جوجل وغيرت مجال
الهواتف الذكيه وبدها تشجع الناس انهم
يستخدم الذكيه فلذلك الواقع الافتراضي
حاليا بالشكل
قاعد تمشي عليه ما اتوقع انه راح ينجح
يمكن يكون عليه كبيره حتى الان اللي
قاعدين بشكل كبير هي الرهان اللي اخذتها
سناب شات اللي هو الواقع المعززه
مجال قاعدين ينجح وقعد يكبر بشكل كبير قد
ينمو خلال السنوات القادمه زي ما تنوي
سناب شات انها تنمو خلال سنوات القادمه
لكن الواقع الافتراضي قد يكون ناجح خلال
خمس سنوات قادمه لكن مو بالشكل اللي احنا
نعرفه ومو بشكل او الطريقه اللي قاعد
نستخدمها الفتره الحاليه طيب احنا هنشوف
تراجع يبدو من مارك ذكر برك على هذا
الموضوع لانه يعني يبدو هو كان اكثر واحد
متحمس لهذا الموضوع
الطريقه اللي راح يتقبل فيها المستخدم
الواقع الافتراضي بشكل كبير جدا كبير في
حياتك
اي شخص يستخدم الواقع يعني من صداع يعاني
من غثيان يعاني من مشاكل جدا مختلفه ما
تقدر تعيش في هذا العالم اكثر من 45 دقيقه
الفيسبوك نفسه حاليا في مذكره داخليه
كانوا يشكون انا من عزوف الموظفين من
استخدام منصه والدخول عليها لما هم نفسهم
يدخلوا عليها طيب يعني اذا تتذكر عبد الله
قبل كم سنه كانت كل الدراسات اللي جلسه
بتطلع ومثلا كل الاشياء اللي يقول لك
الوظيفه الحلم وما الى ذلك كلهم كانوا
بيذكروا انه التوظيف في هذه الشركات مثلا
جوجل فيسبوك او متى وهذه الشركات التقنيه
بيقول لك انه هذا هو احسن مجال في همم
للتوظيف فعليا هل الان لا زالوا الاحسن في
هذا المجال ولا طلع من الموضوع لا كله زي
بعضه
هو لازالت تعتبر من الشركات الكبيره كل
شركات التقنيه تعتبر من الشركات الكبيره
وتعتبر يعني على قولتهم خيار امثل للتوظيف
لكن التضخم الكبير اللي صار خلال سنوات
الماضيه وايضا التوظيف الغير محسوب عواقبه
سبب مثل هذه المشاكل في شركات نجفه من هذه
المشكله في شركات كبيره ما سمعنا اسماءهم
استغلت عن الموظفين ليه لان كانوا
الموظفين فيها مدروس عكس بقيه الشركات
اللي كان النمو بشكل كبير جدا كبير وكانت
في قرارات جدا لو رجعنا خلال همم سنوات
الماضيه كانت شركات تعمل في مجال الاغذيه
ما ودي استنى اسم بعينه لكن شركات تعمل في
مجال الاغديه كانت تعتبر الحلم وكانت
مغريه جدا كبير لان مستثمرين
اصبحت اقل همم اغراء بسبب انه وصلت الى
المرحله اللي اقصى شيء ممكن توصلات فهل
هذه المرحله هي اقصى شيء ممكن توصل لها
الشركات الانتقاليه اتوقع ان الشركات
التقنيه لا زال عندها مجال خاصه
مايكروسوفت وابل جوجل بسبب اعتمادهم على
مختلف تقنيات وايضا وجود فرصه جدا ذهبيه
في المنازل الذكيه خاصه مع اطلاق ما ترز
او منصه ماترز
ايضا موجود فرصه جدا كبيره فذكائر الصناعي
وجود فرصه اكثر بكثير في مجال السيارات
ذاتيه القياده اتوقع انه مستقبل افضل
مايكروسوفت وجوجل وامازون قد يكون مريح
اكثر من الشبكات التواصل اجتماعيه لان
الشبكات التواصل اجتماعيه قاعد تمر بمرحله
الكود جدا كبيره خلال فتره الماضيه مع
مشاكل خصوصيه وقله الاعلانات واتجاه كل
محتوى الى من الصادق منافسه فلذلك الان
همم اللعبه تغير
ما تتوقع في امور كثيره راح تغير خلال
السنوات القادمه طبعا غير المشاكل
السياسيه اللي كلهم داخلين فيها يعني غصبا
عنهم او بارادتهم طيب على العموم نحن
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا عبر
رسوم من الرياضه المحرره التقني في
العربيه عبد الله السبع شكرا لك عبد الله